I would say that I love my family and
then I love cheese Wow Wow Mazal cheese
or dogs hmm tied for first
wow thanks a second we're gonna try a
name as many Jesus as we can in three
minutes are you feeling Kayla I'm ready
to cut the cheese
God that was so cheesy how do you feel
that cheese Clark I mean I grew up in
Texas where basically we're not giving
milk we're getting K so we're just just
melted cheese I've heard of queso and
cereal is queso and cereal no three two
one
Asiago pepper jack Parmesan Swiss
provolone cheddar brie Swiss monster Oh
Colby Monterey pecorino sure paneer
it's gorgonzola pepper lettuce what's
the gene cheese creer yeah career that's
what I was gonna say good huh
dang it's so bad what's a cheese you put
in lasagna the you know there's Kayla oh
it's kind of chunky it has a letter at
the end of the alphabet in it see it
ends in a Z that has that letter to them
and you can only say it in an Italian
voice I think I said
[Music]
strange Heath yeah let's see okay we
already say pepperjack
no he said called that Colby yeah
cottage cheese
oh yeah you don't think I just ate a
cheese is aged cheddar finely shaved
cheese no shredded doesn't count
then just know it's a form of it but if
we think about cheese blends what is it
what is in pepper jack Monterey
I cannot think of the cheese that goes
in lasagna no there's mozzarella and
there's the chunky boys yeah it goes
into layers it's the layers of the
lasagna ricotta so bad we should we
should go to achieve as I'm embarrassed
we did a disservice to cheese out there
yeah we need to go do some homework
right now
you